[MUSIC]
Hi welcome, my name is Kirsten Moss and
I'm the Dean of Admissions at Stanford and
also oversee financial aid as well.
And today I'm excited for not one,
not two, but three reasons.
We have never done a panel on our
leadership curriculum before.
This is an inaugural, [COUGH] excuse me.
An inaugural event, the first time.
So and the reason it's important to us is
many of our candidates say that one of
the reasons that they've
chosen Stanford or
to apply to Stanford is because of our
distinctive leadership curriculum.
So it's exciting for the first time,
[COUGH] to make sure that we can
really share what happens when
you come to Stanford and think about
developing your leadership skills.
The third reason that I'm excited is
I am a certified leadership geek,
I guess you would say.
And that's for the last two decades I've
been studying leadership development and
assessment.
One of my most favorite memories has been
actually being a leadership facilitator
in one of our elective classes here called
Interpersonal Dynamics for seven years.
In addition to being
the Dean of Admissions here,
I've also run Career Services
at Harvard Business School.
And finally, worked in the private
sector and executive recruiting,
helping coach senior leaders and
assess their talent and develop as well.
So lots of reasons, I can't wait to hear
what our students are going to say today.
So let's get started,
what are we going to cover in the panel?
Today we want to talk about just introduce
briefly to our leadership curriculum at
Stanford, and
then meet our five panelists.
So today is also unusual because each of
our panelists are from the class of 2021,
they just graduated, woo hoo.
And the reason, usually we have some
alumni and current students but we
really wanted to sort of meet the nuts and
bolts of how we develop leaders on campus.
So getting five students who've just
been through the program will be
really helpful.
We'll kick off with some Q&A.
So I'll have some questions that I'll give
to each of the panelists and then we'll
save the last at least 20 to 25 minutes to
hear questions from you in the audience.
So you can use your Q&A box as we go,
feel free to be adding questions.
And then when the time comes, I'll start
drawing from that list, all right?
So let's ensure that we can
introduce all of our panelists.
So Brian, you can see their backgrounds.
We'll keep this up while
we do our introductions.
All from the class, as I said, of 2021.
So Brian, I'd love for you to get
started and maybe you could just tell us
why you were thinking about an MBA and
why you decided on Stanford.
>> Sure, thanks Kristen.
Hi, everyone, thanks for being here.
It's great to be with my classmates
again and to be with all of you.
The leadership development curriculum at
Stanford is really the primary reason why
I applied.
I think as compact without going
through the whole pre-GSB resume.
I worked for nine years before
I came to business school.
And so the big question in my mind
was whether it was worth coming to
business school at that point.
And so I was much more interested in
applying to Stanford Business School than
business school generally.
And the reason for that was because of the
emphasis on leadership development here.
Over the course of my career,
generally I worked at Bain before and
then was at the startup.
And in both of those cases, I had mentors
whom I just really admired because of
their ability to develop others and
the way that they developed me.
And what all those people had in
common is they graduated from the GSB.
And so when I was asking them about how
they became the leaders that they became.
They pointed to specific
classes that they had taken at
the GSB as well as classmates
who had become lifelong friends.
And these were mentors who were 15,
20 years older than I was.
And so, the GSB has always loomed large
as a place where you can go and really,
the school's focus on developing the whole
person was something that really
appealed to me.
So it was very much because of
this leadership curriculum.
>> Awesome, thanks, Brian.
How about you, Kerry?
>> Yeah, hi everyone, Kerry here.
There were three reasons for
me for deciding to go to Stanford.
Brian touched on one which was
the leadership curriculum.
The other two reasons will be first and
foremost, the culture.
I got the opportunity to attend seminars
like this, but not necessarily leadership
curriculum seminars, but just get to
speak to current students and alumni.
And it was just wonderful to hear about
people who are constantly challenging one
another, but
not in competition with one another.
And I think that's the spirit of
collaboration is something that I wanted
to be a part of.
And a bias for action and
kind of a willingness to embrace
failure as a way to grow.
So you fail forward and
learn from your experiences.
And then the other reason, the third one,
would be the Stanford
ecosystem more broadly.
So I wanted come to the GSB,
partly because I would be at Stanford and
Stanford, as you all know, has so
many wonderful renowned programs.
So I did a dual degree program.
I wanted to be able to interact
with students from other programs
within the Stanford ecosystem.
So that was primarily another
reason why I chose to come.
>> Awesome, thanks.
How about you, Sarah?
>> Hi, everyone, Sarah, it's really,
really good to be here.
I came to the GSB because I
wanted to start a company and
I really couldn't think of
a better place to do that.
The seed was planted actually when
I was an undergrad at Stanford.
So I did my Undergrad and
my Master's at Stanford then came back for
round three for the MBA.
And I just remember interacting with
GSB students in some of my classes and
being really impressed by the
thoughtfulness that they put into things
like group projects or communication.
And I was very impressed and
bookmarked that for later.
Similar to Brian actually,
one of my old bosses at a startup that I
worked at prior to the GSB was an alum.
And I remember he had us all give a talk
and if you've heard of this traditional
golf talk, you actually give your
life story in front of the class.
And he had us do that in front of our
team, which I thought was really weird,
sort of invasive.
But it became kind of a cornerstone
of how our team gelled together and
how we really got to know each other.
I've since gone on to become a talk
coach while I was at the GSB.
So that was a big reason why I came was
sort of the influences that I saw from my
boss prior to GSB.
And then when I wanted to start a company,
I knew that the GSB was going to
provide me with so many resources,
both in terms of personal development but
also in terms of the start up itself.
And that has definitely proven to be true,
and I'm happy to talk more about that.
>> Awesome, that's great.
How about Francisca?
>> Hi everyone, Francisca.
So I decided to come to the GSB or
business school generally because my
GRE that I had taken five years
earlier was expiring, and
I really had to apply in that one year.
But beyond that,
I think in a word, growth.
Growth, in terms of career,
I was working at a nonprofit in
Vietnam that was terribly mismanaged.
And I knew that the next time that I
worked in an organization like that,
I wanted to know how
to make things better.
Two, I think in terms
of personal confidence.
And confidence, I'm saying that broadly,
like understanding myself truly, and
deeply, and knowing what I wanted,
was really key.
And also the confidence to go out and
get it.
And then three, I would say growth
in terms of personal wellness.
I thought a big thing for me for business
school was taking a step back, and
looking at my patterns, and
looking at my habits, and
kind of rethinking how I wanted to live.
And so a lot of things leading
me into business school but
Stanford specifically some of
what my fellow panelists said.
I think the focus on
leadership was important, but
also kind of the vibe
that I got from students.
People were looking for
similar things to me, and
I thought that would be a good
Environment to grow in.
>> So, thanks.
And how about you, Abby?
>> Thanks, Kirsten.
Hi, everyone.
I came to the GSB, I think we've touched
on a lot of reasons around leadership.
And mine was also very much,
basically my entire decision to
get my MBA was around leadership.
But I will highlight three dimensions
of it that I think were important for
me in making the decision.
So the first is that, I wanted
a place that was going to force and
push me to self-reflect and think about
what are my own strengths and weaknesses.
And what's going to help give me both
a toolkit to do that self-reflection and
then take that feedback and learn those
things about myself and apply them.
And actually have that sort of
really pragmatic aspect to it.
The second reason which
is more aspirational,
and people kind of touched on this.
But I have a really important boss in my
work experience who had actually gone
to Stanford and had been an Arbuckle
fellow and a whole bunch of things,
who I think it's still probably
the single greatest mentor that I have.
And is the first person I go to to bounce
decisions off of and ideas off of.
And she was really good in I think both
determining kind of when to give me
the warm hug approach and
when to give me a little bit
more of a butt-kicking approach.
And just understanding that there's
a whole array of tools that matter.
And kind of knowing a person really deeply
and being the person that I turn to.
And so, I wanted to be able to add one of
my biggest aspirations career-wise is to
be able to pay that forward and to be
able to do that same to other people.
And so that was a big piece of it.
And then the third and final thing is
that, I actually come from an industry
that I am kind of the odd
person out in the room a lot.
I worked in sports, and so
often I would walk into rooms that
were heavily not looking like me.
It was often very male,
I was kind of the outsider.
And that had a lot of interesting
implications for how I conducted myself at
work, and the groups that I was able to
be a part of, and how I would influence.
And figuring out how to master different
ways of doing that and how to lead a group
of people who weren't like me, and
kind of that diversity in different ways.
And how to respond to it myself
are really the reasons for applying.
>> It's really helpful.
Thanks, I'm going to go back
to one more slide here.
And I love the introductions you gave,
because many of you talked about
this a moment coming to Stanford
to turn inside yourself, and
actually develop who you are,
know yourself.
And really that's what leadership
development curriculum is all about at
Stanford.
The question we want you to answer is,
why should someone follow you?
Maybe you're out there in the audience and
you're someone who, whenever you're in
a room can kind of distill the critical
issues people are speaking about.
Or maybe you're someone who's
willing to challenge the sacred cow,
challenge assumptions.
Or maybe you're the person in the room
who notices that someone else isn't
participating and
you include them and ask them, hey,
I'd really love to know
what you're thinking.
So all these are different
leadership behaviors.
But we want to help you
answer that question of,
what are you doing that
you're doing really well?
But also understand the language of
leadership enough to begin to grow into
these other behaviors.
And after studying leadership for 20
years, both in the classroom academically,
and then also in the private sector,
one thing is very clear to me.
That leadership cannot be learned from
a book, it can't be learned from a case.
You actually have to go
through the un-comfort and
the stress of trying on these new
behaviors, and understanding things
about yourself you haven't seen
before in a really safe environment.
So we do that in many ways at Stanford,
from the core curriculum and
leadership labs, to some of our elective
courses that you'll hear about today.
You can see listed and
even more structured opportunities,
whether they're extracurriculars,
or something like Arbuckle fellows,
low keynotes or talk program.
So I'm sure each of the panelists will
give us some of those highlights.
So with that introduction,
I'll stop sharing, and
I'm going to now ask
the panelists a few questions.
I'm going to now ask each of you to start
out, and really, if you can think about
the one class experience, or even resource
that was most critical in helping you with
your own leadership development while
you're on campus in the last couple years.
I'd love to hear that.
And Abby, maybe I'll start with you.
We'll go backwards this time.
>> Yeah, I mean, there's a lot of
things if I had to pick one one.
Gosh, I think I would say there was
a class called Paths to Power that I took
in my second year in the winter quarter.
And I think that for
a combination of timing reasons and
that you've gone through.
At the point in which you take an elective
like that in the winter quarter of your
second year, you've kind of gotten
a little bit of a foundation in terms
of some of the leadership things.
You've gone through Led labs in
the fall of your first year.
There's often a lot of other
opportunities you've had up to that,
including things like,
I was also a fellow, etc.
But the timing of that I think was really
helpful because it was a really good way
of consolidating and reframing a lot
of the things I learned in one class.
And being very pragmatic about how
do you apply some of these things?
And I think that the biggest takeaway for
me of it which was bit of a shock to
the system at times but also helpful,
is that when you're given
a toolkit whatever it might be,
You have a lot of power with that, right,
of ways in which you deploy it, etc.
And that gives you the responsibility
to be intentional about it,
in terms of everything that you've
learned, and the skills you have.
And the ways in which you apply them, you
have to own whether they ended up being
kind of the right things or
the wrong things.
And in the context of things like power,
there are questions that you could ask
around, like how much do you want to
assert yourself in a room or space?
And will that result in, how will that
impact a certain relationship, or
how will that impact a certain thing?
And there are going to be trade-offs.
And part of that is you have this toolkit
where you get to assess all the different
options, and you kind of have to be really
intentional about the ways in which you
go about it and own those decisions.
And again, you're not going to
be perfect every time, but it's
about kind of ownership of that in saying
there is no one perfect way of doing it.
But you have to own it and
take responsibility for
the ways in which you engage in whatever
that setting and whatever your goal is.
So that was a really good learning,
it sounds corny but
with great power comes great
responsibility, right?
When you have all these things that
you're given in that toolkit, it's a lot.
And figuring out the ways that
you're comfortable with owning that,
that's kind of the critical pieces.
You have all these ways that
you can make a decision.
The thing is that you have to be able
to live with that decision however it
is that you make it.
>> Great, thank you, Abby.
How about you, Sarah?
>> I think the class that impacted me the
most was called the Lean Launchpad, and
there's actually a class out
of the School of Engineering.
But it brings together multidisciplinary
teams across engineering,
business school, all over the university,
to start a startup in one quarter.
It is really intense, and it was the first
time it was our winter quarter, so
we were so new.
We didn't know anyone and
we had to put together this team.
And then every single week
basically had to pit it,
because nothing went
right most of the time.
[LAUGH] And
I think on key lesson that I take away and
still practice today is
how to make decisions.
And when should you make
a decision based on consensus, and
when is that actually not appropriate.
And for me that was a huge learning
because I was a product manager
before the GSB.
I didn't have any formal authority until a
lot of my decision-making I thought had to
be done by consensus.
And so that's how I approached
this in Lean Launchpad, and
it created a lot of interesting
dynamics within the team.
There's a lot of places
where it wasn't effective.
And so one key learning for example is, we
started making decisions by each coming in
with a really well-formed,
articulated hypothesis and argument.
And instead of asking people to vote,
we would have everyone essentially debate
around the table and then ask people,
what is your conviction on
a level from one to 10?
And then on some decisions,
we decided, actually,
this person is the owner and
they're going to own that decision.
And so how we navigate decisions and how
teams are collected and formed, were huge,
huge learning through that class.
That I never would have gotten if,
to your point, a person read a book,
read a case, seeing it play out
in your life was so powerful.
>> Wow, and that's so cool too because
it's a class that I don't think of is
typically is part of the main
leadership curriculum but fascinating,
that's awesome.
How about you, Kerry?
And it can be a class experience,
resource, anything you like.
>> Nothing,
I'll go on the experience part,
I think I was fortunate enough to serve
the student body as co-president.
And student government was not
something I had envisioned myself
doing prior to coming to the GSB, so
it was definitely a stretch experience.
But it was a perfect opportunity to take
everything we're learning in Lead Labs and
in all the other leadership
curriculum classes,
why should people follow you and
put it into practice in real time?
So for instance,
I got to work on my communication skills,
especially [INAUDIBLE] pandemic where you
have to be talking to people about things
that no one really knows about.
So that was something that
was important for me,
learning how to delegate responsibility,
building camaraderie amongst my peers,
practicing empathy, especially at
a time when everyone needed it.
Putting yourself in
the shoes of others and
understanding how best to support them.
So that for
me was definitely the experience that I
know I will be using in 10, 20 years,
even when you have a crisis, just knowing
how to function during that time.
>> Wow, yeah, and Kerry,
others may not know this but
you were really the student representative
on the committee that made many decisions
about how to get through the pandemic
with classes and everything else.
Was that fair description?
>> Yeah, it was a wonderful kind
of collaborative experience,
where I got to become really good friends
with the administrators, the deans, staff.
Understanding the people behind the scenes
that make the GSB just a magical place it
is was also a wonderful experience for me.
>> Not an easy job, I'm sure this year,
[LAUGH], how about you,
Brian, what's most memorable for you?
>> I was thinking, I also was just typing
in that Kerry's an incredible leader.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And we were so
lucky to have him as one of our
presidents, so plus a million at that.
I think we're all kind of avoiding talking
about Touchy Feely because that's the big
one that everyone knows about.
But the reality is that's a great class
and there are a lot of other classes where
you get to apply that same experiential
learning cycle where you can say, hey,
I'm going to make it concrete.
I think for me, the big realization for
me was that leadership,
it's not like a personality style.
It's not like you have one
fixed leadership type,
it's actually a suite of behaviors and
you can try on different ones.
And some of them may be muscles that are
underdeveloped that you need to practice.
Some ones, you just may not like using,
like Abby's talking about in the past.
You may see different approaches and
see the results against them and say, hey,
I don't like using that one.
Either because it's uncomfortable or
maybe you examined why it
makes you uncomfortable.
And maybe you decide that's just not
going to be one of the ones I'm using.
So the class that actually gave me
the most of those learning cycles was
the negotiations class, through the loss.
And so this gets at, there was
a negotiations class in the GSB as well,
I just happened to do a seminar in
the law school that was full corner.
And what was really cool about that,
is every single week you had an in-depth
negotiation where different class
members had to play different roles.
And you would explicitly reflect
beforehand on what your approach was going
to be and why.
And then at the end of the class, even
though you were only in your negotiation,
everyone would enter in the outcomes.
And you could see the full range of
different approaches people had taken and
how it had gone for different folks.
And you basically realize there's
no right or wrong approach, but
there are trade-offs that
Abby's talking about,
and trade-offs that you
have to be willing to own.
And as you think about going into
negotiations in the future, and
these aren't just high stakes ones.
These are any kind of negotiation
about where we're going for dinner?
>> [LAUGH]
>> [INAUDIBLE] in the class, but
you think about these things,
it was a really valuable way to practice
these action impact models that you learn.
And as an Arbuckle fellow or when you're
choosing okay, what new behaviors am I
going to try on, how do I expect this
to land on the other person, and
then in what ways was I surprised?
And what was different than I expected,
and how do I want to change my behavior
next time in order to better align my
actual impact with my desired action?
So that class was the one where
I just got the most reps and
probably learned the most from doing.
>> Awesome, and one of the things Stanford
is known for is being able to take coding
classes across the street because you can
take them in any of the graduate schools.
So maybe a little, Brian, about was that
hard to find the course, take the course,
how easy or hard was that?
>> It's super easy,
that class was one where just I've been
talking to other classmates about,
hey, if I want to get some reps doing,
I'm uncomfortable negotiating.
I actually think it was Sarah, [LAUGH]
who was the one who recommended it to me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> My gosh, this one is great, and
I remember kind of geeking out with
her at dinner one night hearing about
a negotiation she was preparing for,
and I just took it the next quarter.
But it's really easy to do those, I think
folks will do classes in med school and
a lot of us take the computer science
class just because you're at Stanford,
you can try something totally different.
So it's really easy to do that and
it's a great complement.
>> Awesome, that's great, and Francisca.
>> Sure, I think the one
that really crystallized for
me was almost the very first day at the
GSB, you do this desert survival exercise.
Where, basically, you're put in
a room with fellow peers, and
you're told that you
landed in a desert and
you have to choose and prioritize
a list of stuff that you take with you.
And I'm not going to tell
you what the right list is,
but it's a surprising array of
things that you should prioritize.
And afterwards, you're recorded and
you watch the video of yourself doing
it and you kind of talk through it.
And the group that you're with is your
Leadership Labs group that you're with for
an entire quarter.
And I guess that even just
in the first week allowed me
to kind of better reflect
on who I am in groups, and
who I want to be and
what are the gaps there.
And then later on, I decided to apply to
be an Arbuckle fellow which I guess we'll
talk about later.
But then I got to leave groups through
that exercise and think about, okay,
you can't change essentially who you are,
but you can try to see what can I do to
enhance how I show up in groups and
how I show up as a leader?
And I think it was just right away,
it hit me in the face, what,
it was going to be a learning journey.
>> Francisca,
would you mind sharing something,
because that was a wonderful example,
to make it concrete for the audience?
Is there something you learned about
how you showed up that you put into or
you worked on or developed more?
Or is that too personal I want to be,
[CROSSTALK]
>> Yeah, I'm happy to, so my group was
right away one of the guys came in,
military background.
He's like, I got this, [LAUGH] racks,
knuckles, gets to work and
he was totally wrong about everything-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Which he was really apologetic for
afterwards, but
I realized throughout the whole time,
I was, hey guys,
our time is tight we gotta keep moving.
How about we do this,
how about we do this?
And it crystallized that I'm
really process oriented, And
that is a very real skill that
some people will have less of.
And so it helps to put words to what
kind of thinker and presence I have.
And then also how to counteract what,
there's a big ideas people or
there's people who stay quiet and
how to bring all those things in.
So that was my kind of
journey was realizing that,
and then kind of focusing on that
later and enhancing that as a skill.
>> Awesome, great.
We had one question come in from the chat,
I'd love to just ask you,
I think it's a great question.
So for anyone that we met, can you
describe a time at the GSB when you were
pushed way out of your comfort zone but
ultimately grew in your
leadership skills because of it?
So we got a little taste
of that from Francisca.
Anyone else want to take that on?
And all of you have had
incredible leadership development
opportunities on campus.
Anybody want to answer that?
>> I can go ahead and-
>> Great, have it, Love.
>> Yeah, so in your first quarter in
Stanford, you take a class called
lead labs, which is the class Francisca
has talked a little bit about,
the desert survival activity.
And actually around week, I believe
it's week five or six of the curriculum,
you do something, which is feedback
to everyone in your squad.
So you have a squad, I think was
mentioned, of six people or so, and then
an Arbuckle leadership fellow, which is a
second year, who helps kind of facilitate.
And in that feedback session,
you kind of talk about like who makes you
feel heard, and who makes you feel seen.
And I had a member of my squad, who, it's
not that anything had actually happened,
there was no real conflict or
anything like that.
But I said to him, I feel like sometimes
you dismiss me and that you don't like me,
and I don't know that's true.
But that's something that I've
internalized, and I don't know why?
And I don't know if that's true,
but it's something that I feel,
which was a really scary
thing to say aloud.
Because again, like I said,
there was no real conflict.
It was just the sense of that,
like there was something there and
I couldn't really explain
why it existed but it did.
And it turned into the probably still the
single most productive conversation I've
had at the GSB,
which was this person who is from
a very different background from me.
Looks very different from me,
has very different kind of interests,
passions, etc.
Looking at me and saying, you're right,
I've kind of felt the same thing too.
And again, they're not being a major
fight, they're not even had been somebody
saying, you said something to me that
I didn't like, there was none of that.
It was just, I've had this impression of
you since you walked in, you're a blond
haired, blue eyed, big personality,
kind of likes to fill up a room.
And I just figured that we would
never be friends and that you and
I would never really actively
spend time together.
And that you were going to just occupy
a completely different space than I was.
And so I decided not to prioritize
getting to know you more, etc.
And that started a whole conversation,
right,
around impressions that we had of
each other and what that meant.
And it got us to a really powerful place,
I would say, of friendship and
he's still someone that I'm actually
probably very, very close to at the GSB,
who checks me on a lot of things and
I check him on a lot of things.
But I think it drove a couple of lessons
for me that were really important.
I think the first was that, weirdly,
especially when you're talking about soft
skills or kind of these other core
competencies that we don't talk about,
where you can't name
something in a spreadsheet.
Often, what you're feeling are your
instincts, even though you can't name
them and might be like it's not this
thing that I can explain logically.
That doesn't make it any less real or
any less present at that time.
And it's something that I think,
as a leader, has to be acknowledged,
even if you can't quantify it.
I think, two, it really taught me how to
start thinking about the conversations
that are really difficult and scary to
have around what is going on between us?
And talking about naming that thing and
then having a really difficult
conversation around it.
That's ultimately very productive and it's
led to some very close friendships, but
again, it's really scary
thing to do in the moment.
And then finally, it really kind of hit
home for me a couple of things that I
need to recognize about myself in
any situation that I show up in,
which is that I show up
in a very certain way.
I am somebody who can be pretty loud and
is willing to speak up first.
And I look a certain way, and I dress
a certain way, and I act a certain way.
And that can be very approachable and
very warm and
friendly to certain groups of people.
And to others, it might be very
alienating and understanding, okay,
what are the situations in which this
might be alienating and how do I want it?
It comes back to kind of owning the
decisions you make of I like to show up
this way,
it feels like an expression of myself.
But then for someone to whom
it doesn't resonate with them,
how do I want to engage with that?
And how do I kind of show up for them?
And how do I approach them and
thinking about with every kind of, again,
every choice you make,
you are bringing people in, but
you also might be kind
of throwing people off.
And so
thinking about that very deliberately and
knowing that something that happens, even
when it is just showing up in a classroom.
And being like, hi, good morning and
being very excited and
knowing that's not everyone's style.
And so getting a sense of that and knowing
that that's choices that you can make, and
that you can kind of lean into I think
was really powerful for me to learn, and
it started very early.
>> Wow, thank you, Abby, for sharing that.
All right, Anna,
you had a question that was very similar
to another one I was going to ask.
Basically, any thoughts or insights on how
you thought about leadership before coming
to the GSB versus now?
So similar to where Abby was going, but
some big learning aha,
and how did you get there?
So anyone can go next.
How about you, Brian?
Yeah, thanks.
>> Yeah, this was a big aha for me.
I had applied for the Arbuckle
programme because of this curriculum
on teaching about leadership
coaching in particular.
And I think when I had applied to that,
I equated leadership coaching with
managing or mentoring, and one of the-
>> Can I jump in for a second, Brian?
Will you explain,
I don't know that everyone in the audience
knows what an Arbuckle fellow is.
So it'd be great for
you to get the top level too, it's great
>> Sure, so,
high level, we talked a lot about
this leadership labs class.
So that is a first quarter
class that every MBA one takes.
And each of those squads of six
people is led by one second year MBA.
And they're not the teacher in that class,
they're kind of a facilitator.
And in order to facilitate that, those
second years are called Arbuckle fellows,
and you have to apply for this program.
And if you are selected as an Arbuckle
fellow, you take touchy freely, your
spring quarter of your first year, so you
tend to get to take a little bit early.
And then, your second year,
you're doing three different things,
kind of three parallel tracks that
are part of leadership development.
The first is you're in a class
called leadership coaching,
which is a two-quarter long class, where
you are having regular weekly sessions
with readings on academic content
related to leadership coaching.
And in parallel to that,
you're also having a hands-on practical,
which from the leadership
fellow's perspective,
means you are learning by
trying to lead the squad.
And I think from the first
year's perspective, I thought,
the second year really knows what they're
doing, and I really admired my leaders.
From the secondaries perspective,
I have no idea what I'm doing,
but I learned a lot because
I messing up [INAUDIBLE].
But it actually is a very hands-on way
of learning about leadership coaching
by doing.
And so track one is content,
track two is practicum.
The third is about
a community where you have a,
it's not called a squad, but
it functions like a squad.
Or it's five other Arbuckle fellows who
meet us weekly and you're sharing about
your learning challenges, and
getting support and one on one coaching.
Over the course of this curriculum.
So it is a pretty rich three quarter
long starting in the spring of your
first year and continuing through
the winter of your second year,
where you're getting classroom learning,
hands on learning, and peer support, and
is a longer answer, but does that-
>> That's helpful, yeah.
Thanks, Brian, so your learning was, yeah.
>> Okay, so my learning was,
leadership coaching is totally
different from managing or mentoring.
And a lot of times the ladder, this
managing mentoring is about optimizing
performance, helping people
achieve their short term goals.
And coaching is much less about achieving
the short term performance goals,
as helping the person that your coaching
discover the answers for themselves.
And fundamentally,
it's about expanding their sense of
the choices that are available to them.
Helping them decide which choices
are most appealing to them, and
helping them build confidence in their
ability to pursue those choices.
And it's really about not telling them
what's best, not giving them advice,
not even being anxious to
reach the right answer.
It's about helping them
explore the landscape, and
helping them grow in self awareness,
and helping them grow and
feeling capable of trying
on these new behaviors.
And a lot of that, I guess to go back to
that earlier question about going way
outside your comfort zone, a lot of
the things that a coach can do is help
identify areas that are just a little
bit outside of their comfort zone.
But that might then let them try a new
behavior that's not super scary, but
isn't that 15% stretch zone.
And those are the ways that
a coach can really help, and
it's super different from
being a mentor or a manager.
And so that was a real
expansion of mindset for me.
>> That's cool.
Thank you, Brian.
We've gotten a couple questions
already from the chat.
I want to make sure, Sarah,
you're a talk coach,
we haven't talked at all about that.
I think that's such a cool part
of our leadership development.
Would you mind maybe talking
about its influence on you, and
how you became a coach?
>> Sure, so Tucker, I briefly mentioned
it but it's essentially this tradition,
where every single week two members of
the class get up either in person or
later virtually and
share their life in 30 minutes.
So it's this incredible tradition
because 30 minutes is a long time.
And people are so open and vulnerable and
generous with this community, and
really opening up and
sharing who they are.
And it's not professional,
it is deeply personal.
For me as a coach,
I wanted to do it ironically because
I did not want to give my own talk.
But I loved the idea of talking,
I was like, I'll let others go.
I'll support them, and I did not realize
that talk coaches have to give a talk.
And so I got that out of the way pretty
early, and giving a talk itself was really
transformational, when else you have
the opportunity to re examine your life,
make sense of it, and
then share it with a room.
And I think being a coach for me, I think
to Brian's earlier point, it's not,
I used to be so focused on, okay, there's
output that we're all creating here.
There's a 30 minute talk and I'm going to
get you there, and here are the steps.
And I sort of halfway through the fall
quarter, stepped back and said,
it's about allowing this person to have
space to answer questions for themselves.
And I can be a mirror back to them.
And so I think about that for coaching
broadly and being really a mirror and
someone to help ask questions and guide,
but ultimately, it's their process,
it's their output.
And I am just always blown away by
the talks we hear every single week,
even if I've heard it five times, I'm
still in tears [LAUGH] every single week.
It's been really special for me.
>> Awesome and just to keep you on
the hotspot, Sarah for a minute longer.
One of the things I
love about Stanford is,
we think about leadership as also building
your brand and being able to communicate.
So top is part of that knowing
what you value, who you are,
you also did low keynote and you were
a TA for winning writing, I remember.
So you've had a whole
brand building experience,
any highlights on those
two things as well?
>> Yeah, thanks for bringing those up.
So on the keynote in particular,
that was exactly why I did it.
So low keynote, for those who don't know
is sort of that TED style talk that you
can give, and you do at the big
stage at Siemens Auditorium.
It's really high production
value of things.
We just going to [LAUGH] and
I did it on a topic that is
really near and dear to my heart.
It's how we should re-imagine aging and
the process of growing older.
And also really strategic because
the startup I'm working on is
in the aging space.
And so I wanted to have a piece of content
out there that was really professional,
that I was really proud of,
that I could put it on my LinkedIn,
and send to investors.
And also, I don't think many people know
this, but I actually do not like public
speaking, I have kind of a around it
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, it was also an opportunity to
push myself way outside my comfort
zone and deliver a nine minute really
rehearsed Professional Speech,
and it's been awesome.
For winning writing, I love writing,
I actually, and Abby was also TA for
that class.
>> Awesome.
>> Glenn Kramon, if you have
a chance to take a class with him,
I would highly recommend,
he is just the best.
And so for me it was more about getting
the opportunity to spend time with Glenn.
That really drew me into that opportunity.
>> Awesome, and the output of that class,
I always find fascinating, right?
Because you're writing opinion pieces,
is that right?
>> Yeah, so the capstone piece
is that you write an OP ED, and
Glenn is a reporter at the New York times,
and editor in New York times.
And he will go above and
beyond to get you published.
He has an outrageous email chains, trying
to get you published every which way,
and he will go lay out over
his skis to do it for you.
He's amazing, and we'll advocate for
his students literally for
decades after they graduate.
>> Awesome, thank you.
I'm going to start switching now
to the questions in the chat.
So Michael asked one, and ten others
that they'd love to hear the answer.
What causes Professor
situations from the GSPD,
you believe you will go back and
reference?
The most should be people and
companies going for it.
Raise your hand if that resonates.
And all of you are working.
So [LAUGH] this should be
becoming really real to you.
Anyone?
I'm sorry, Carrie,
I didn't see your hand, Carrie, awesome.
>> I can help in here.
So one that I've actually
had to go back and
reference it's called strategic
Pivoting with Allison Kluger.
And it also has Alex Rodriguez,
the baseball legend,
as one of the professors at the class.
And I think what's really important about
the class is similar to winning-writing.
It's about understanding your audience.
And if you want to be a leader,
any leader knows that you have to
know the people you're leading.
And I think every time I have to do stuff,
I'm currently on a short
term internship in sports.
And understanding exactly who I'm speaking
to and understanding how to get buy-in and
exactly how I went to sell myself, because
we all contain multitudes as leaders.
And your different parts of yourself you
want to bring as you're trying to actually
get buy-in regarding different things.
So sometimes I'll go back and
look at the strengths I've identified, and
figure out which things I want to put
at the fore of whatever I'm trying to
bring during a meeting,
and things like that.
And that's actually been very
helpful this summer already.
>> Wow, that's great.
And Allison's another example,
she was a TV reporter, is that right?
Am I getting that right?
So you'll see at Stanford that
in your second year electives,
they're often co-taught by a tenured
faculty member in a lecture,.
Sometimes their individual courses like
Allison's teaching, or Glenn's teaching.
But we'd like to bring practitioners in,
as well as the academics so
you're exposed to the art and
the science of how you need to lead.
That's great, thank you.
Let's go to another one, what has
changed about, and this is from Saya.
I hope I saying it right, Sayale.
What has changed about your leadership
style due to your experiences and
learning at the GSB?
Now, a couple of you,
Abby already had given us an example.
Francisca, tell us.
>> Yeah, so I worked in international
development before, and I had to,
because I was a young woman, I had to
present a really professional image,
which I think is important.
But I kind of came in
thinking I had two hats.
I had personal Francisca and
then I had professional Francisca, and
they were kind of two different things.
There were some similarities,
but not really.
And I realized how much the GSB, and
some people come in just knowing this,
they're just themselves always, I was not.
That collapsing those two ideas and
kind of showing yourself fully
to different teams and showing up truly
as yourself and sharing of yourself.
I know this is entirely the stereotype
of GSB, that it's very touchy-feely,
but it is exactly what I learned,
which is when you show up fully.
And that doesn't mean revealing all of
your secrets all at once or whatever, but
there's a power to it,
because it models what is okay for others.
And as a leader, what you show and
what you share and
how you share it,
it kind of sets the tone.
And I saw that over and over again,
I was part of the Hispanic
Business Student Association, or
even just in interactions with peers,
there was just a lot.
When you kind of share your inner thoughts
a bit more and let people in on kind of
how you're thinking about things,
there's a power to that.
And that was definitely a change
from kind of the professional
facade that I had before the GSB.
>> Francisca,
I find myself just nodding and nodding and
nodding after being a facilitator and
touchy-feely.
I think that's amazing response.
One of the things I always say is we
meet students on your admit weekend,
so I get a chance to meet all of you.
And then two years later as you
walk across that graduation stage,
there's this sense of comfort in your own
skin, and almost feels like some of these
masks have come away, I know, and
touchy-feely, that's how it felt.
But anybody else who took that
class want to speak to this,
because I think it's such a critical
issue of how you learn to do that for
yourself through the class?
Did anyone else take touchy-feely?
Well, yeah.
That's right, all of you.
[LAUGH] Okay, who's going to
speak up on how that class gives
you the opportunity to show
up as more human or whole or
authentic, lots of
the things Francisca said?
>> I can jump in.
I don't want to dominate the discussion,
but I'll say very quickly that similar to
what Francisca said about
bringing all parts of yourself.
That's something that if
you're any form of a minority,
you may have experienced, knowing
that sometimes it can be difficult to
bring all parts of your
identities to bear.
And I think being in
interpersonal dynamics,
you get to have difficult conversations
about how people perceive you and
why that has to do with their
perception of identity.
And also being able to call it and have
conversations about why some things that
may have been said may be problematic.
Or perhaps also bringing understanding
that there's an understanding of best
intention, but you can still give feedback
about how things may land on you.
And I think that makes you more
confident in owning who you are and
walking into rooms
bringing your full self.
So that definitely was critical for
me as part of the interpersonal dynamics.
>> That's great, thank you.
>> I might underline
something that Abby said.
The story that Abby told from her LeAD
Labs experience was a lot of the lesson
that I took from touchy-feely, which is
that sometimes we have feedback that we
want to share and we approach it
as though we're building a case.
And you're only sharing the feedback once
you're sure you have an airtight case, and
that really means that you're
not sharing parts of yourself.
And so sometimes what touchy-feely
also can push you is to provide
feedback where you don't have evidence,
or there's a line that one of my
facilitators said was, the feeling
often arrives before the thought.
And you have a feeling, and then you
kind of, you do this very quickly,
so you don't realize it, but you kind of
scramble to dress it up in fancy language,
or you try and
give it intellectual clothing.
But fundamentally, you just feel sad or
undervalued, or it's just something that
you're almost embarrassed or ashamed
of because it's such a simple feeling.
But naming those impressions, or
at least naming them to yourself,
if not naming them, if you're saying,
hey, I'm feeling dismissed here,
can often provide opportunities for
you to make yourself more known, but
also to build a stronger relationship
with the people that you're working with.
And as fluffy as that can sound,
that can allow you to build trust.
And it doesn't mean that you're suddenly
revealing all parts of yourself, but
you're incrementally building stronger
rapport with the people that you're
working with regularly.
So that was a really powerful learning for
me as well.
>> Brian, is there a way,
I put you on the spot.
I just realized some people might
not know how the class works.
Is there a really short high level answer,
I know it's hard to describe, but for
someone who's never heard about
interpersonal dynamics before?
>> Yeah, I think one way to
think about classes at the GSB
is I've kind of been looking through
my notes since graduating and
it's like there are three
types of classes.
There are the ones where it's
like a new industry maybe and
you're getting a glass bottom boat tour of
an industry that was unfamiliar for you.
For me that was education,
the education industry.
There are other ones where you're
learning new sets of tools and
you're trying something out for the first
time and you're getting lots of reps.
Like that negotiations class, or
there's a corporate financial modeling
class where you learn to build an LBO
model from scratch even if you
have never worked in finance.
There's a third one where it's like,
and this is the last category,
where it's like a new lens for
seeing and understanding the world.
And I think touchy-feely kind of
straddles the second and the third one.
You're learning new ways of
thinking about the world.
You're looking at your interactions and
you're kind of all of a sudden seeing them
diagrammed in your head of, what happened?
This was an attempt to connect with me and
I missed it.
And so now I feel like I'm going to
be more attentive to that.
And then you're also having these
experiential practice groups.
And so the way that's structured in
the class is you have lectures once a week
where they walk through some kind of
content around like, I mentioned bins/s,
this idea of what is the emotional
unit of communication?
And the smallest building block of
that is something that's called a bin,
which is defined as any attempt
to connect with another person.
And might be telling a dad joke, or
smiling at someone when you see them, and
it's just a question of,
does the person acknowledge that or not?
And this is just a new vocabulary,
a new way of thinking about things.
And then after these lecture classes,
you go into what's called a tea group,
which is your learning group.
It's 12 people, and you spend
something like seven hours in a room
together without any clear agenda or
structure and just communicating.
And a lot of what happens in there is
either providing feedback to people or
sharing reactions to the ways
that people have landed on you,
either in that session or in the past.
And it's one of those hands-on
experiential learning courses where you
really do push yourself to share feedback
that maybe is a little more direct
than you're used to giving, or
that reveals a little more of yourself
than you may be comfortable with.
And those relationships
become very strong, actually.
I'm working with someone who was in my
tea group when I was in touchy-feely
because that relationship became like
a peer coaching relationship that
continued past that class, and it was
a really formative experience for me.
>> Awesome, that's great.
Okay, I'm going to read another one,
this is from Dieter.
Through these events, I've heard a lot
about professors being engaged outside
the classroom with students' professional
aspirations and business endeavors.
Does this hold true with
leadership development, or
is that primarily done student
to student more or so?
How are professors?
Well, you could answer generally how
professors sort of empowered you along
your two years and
also specifically if they've
touched you in the leadership side.
Anyway, Abby?
>> Yeah, I'm happy to take that.
I mean, I think on a broad level
we've talked about I know people have
mentioned different professors here
like Glenn Cravens, a great one.
I still talk to him all the time.
I work in marketing, so
he's a great person when writing by etc.
I would say, I think one that fostering
relationships with Russia is the GSB is
one of the I obviously knew coming
in that it was a good idea.
But I don't necessarily know
that I realized how good
an idea it was until I started
using them and leaning on them.
I think I mentioned I've
already started working.
I'm at a start up where I'm now managing
a team of 8 people now we just hired
two more.
And so, and it's my first experience in a
startup environment, I think for one, and
when I've managed people before, it's
been in a much more structured setting.
And so,
in terms of thinking about leadership and
trying to one deploy the lessons of
leadership and thinking about my role.
Is less of a like purely like hey,
so and so please do this and
thinking about them as creative,
resourceful and
whole human beings that I want to
help develop and make successful.
And there's also quite frankly, like
leadership challenges that just come up
right, like having I worked
during part of the GSB as well.
But having people who are not
performing and having to kind of,
have conversations that
are really tough around that.
And having conversations when like,
I don't feel set up for
success that it's much more
nuanced than it used to be like,
I don't feel like I have the data
I need to fix this problem.
It's much more structural across
the organization or things like that,
because we're building a company
we're building a culture.
And I can tell you that there are GSB
professors who I lean on quite heavily
for this.
So, a big one is
Ricky Frankel who is one of
the she's one of the Arbuckle
Leadership Fellow Program leads.
And she was my when I was a fellow
she was my clinic leader and
kind of is just a huge,
huge mentor and coach of mine.
And she's someone who I have role played
many of these conversations with both
while I was at school and
actually since graduating school.
Though it wasn't that long
ago not that far removed, but
still having those conversations and
or respect another one who I have on.
He teaches a course called conversations
and management, which is really around
like, how do you think about the different
ways of having difficult conversations?
What are the assumptions
that you're making?
How do you think about them differently?
And he's someone who I've had a lot of
correspondence with in serving this role
as well of how do I think
about this problem?
What are the things that I'm missing?
Where are my blind spots?
How should I actually like,
can we role play this conversation.
And doing some of that I can tell you
it's like incredibly practical and
very much applicable to the work
that I am doing right now.
And so in some ways, I considered myself
very blessed because I have a reason to
email those people all the time.
But it's also it's really an important
resource that I leaned on a lot as
I've kind of got my as I'm getting my
feet under me in the post school world.
>> How about we wrap up but I'll go
right down the panel any tips to many
we found out 9% of folks were
planning on applying this fall.
So, any tips you might have as they're
facing that application process on things
to think about if they're
thinking about Stanford.
How about you, Brian?
>> Yeah, well, definitely apply.
I think there's a lot of I think
being really clear to yourself and
taking the time before
you write good essays.
I think there's a lot of mechanical
stuff to focus on on the application and
that's all things that you will get done.
But giving yourself a little
bit of space to think about,
what is it you really want to
get out of the experience.
Because oftentimes people focus so
much on applying itself
that there's just such a richness
of opportunity at Stanford,
that you can't just figure
that out once you get there.
And so knowing,
you don't need to have a really,
deliberate clear plan of ABC,
more just saying, If nothing else,
what do I want to get out of
these this year and half.
And how do I want to change and what would
be something that I'd love to be able to
say about myself at
the end of this journey.
And just writing that down for yourself,
you don't have to share with anyone.
But that can help you once you do get
there and you have this huge volume of
things to choose from and
how you want to allocate your time.
That can be something that you'd
revisit that's really helpful and
that can often pull you through
the mechanical work of actually getting
through the application process.
So, good luck.
>> Awesome, thanks Brian and Sarah.
>> I was going to say something similar
to Brian and just really thinking for
yourself what you want out of these
two years because it's an incredible
opportunity.
It's also the scary thing.
I found a really intimidating to be like
what do I want out of these two years?
It's a big daunting.
So, I got some really good advice
to think about it as a hypothesis.
So, come in with a number
of different hypotheses.
And this is also how we run our startup.
So, this is very analogous, but it's like
I have a the person I got this advice from
had a hypothesis that he wanted
to be in the coffee industry.
He wanted to work at a FinTech startup and
he wanted to like run a marathon.
These are not related hypotheses,
but he systematically went out and
did each of those three things and
fell in love with this FinTech startup and
that's what he did after the GSB.
And just taking an experimental
mindset to this and
knowing that you do have time you
do have bandwidth to experiment.
It's not all or nothing really for
me was a mindset change and
how I approach the experience.
>> Thank you, Carrie how about you?
>> Well, first of all I want to reiterate
Brian's apply which with a shoot your shot
because for myself I know I was
there are many times where I wasn't
sure about getting into GSB.
But you won't get in if you don't apply so
100% shoot your shot and
try to get it I think in terms of advice,
I would say two things.
One, have grace for yourself because
it's is a very rigorous process.
And it can be daunting.
There are many times where I had doubt,
but I think have grace and
just keep at it.
And then the second one is try to immerse
yourself into the community in any way
you can.
Whether that's attending programs like
this, it's reaching out to alumni current
students, if you have any connections,
whether it's secondhand.
Just try to try to learn as much as you
can about why the program is right for
you because then it will
come through when you apply.
>> Awesome, Abby, thank you.
>> Yeah, I'm trying not to reiterate all
of the the sage advice my peers here, and
I don't know many things but one thing and
I'm not the Dean of Admissions
either although she's in the room.
But one thing that I do know is Stanford
doesn't want you because you're perfect.
You're not going to be the greatest
leader ever because you're perfect.
The people who you engage with and
meet with and who become close to you and
all of these sorts things.
It's not because you're perfect,
it's because you have the interesting
quirks and flaws and personality traits.
And things that make you and make you lead
in the authentic ways that are you and
that help you engage wherever you are.
Be at Stanford or be it at work wherever
it is the things that make you you.
And so the goal is not perfection.
I think the goal is to kind of
as people have talked about, and
it's I think the start of a journey at
Stanford, right of starting to embrace
those parts of yourself and knowing
that you can bring all of that together.
And so the goal is so
interesting when you're applying
to things like I must be perfect.
And I think actually the reason that
everybody in the community is so amazing.
And what really stands out to me
about it is that everyone wants
an incredible leader because of
their quirks not despite them.
>> Perfect, thank you.
Francisca can you close this out.
>> Yeah, I think first,
put in the work to be who you want to
be regardless of business school.
So, business school is just
one step on the on the path.
If it doesn't work out,
put yourself on that path,
whether it's building habits,
getting to know people,
looking ahead of things,
because this is not the end of the all.
It's just one step on the way.
And the second thing I would
say is stay off poets and
quants and all those websites because
they're just going to stress you out and
they don't really add that
much value to your journey.
>> Awesome.
Well thank all of this panelists for
coming here today.
I've learned a ton and
really appreciate it.
It's so wonderful to see all your
faces as well back together, and
to all the prospects out there.
We appreciate you coming.
Hopefully, you listen to the sage advice,
shoot your shot.
I'll steal from Carrie.
And I hope to get a chance to read
your application this coming fall.
Thanks so much.
[MUSIC]